yo tambien una mama meets Akutan a
zombie aqui donde Scavo sorry DJ gamma
mu meters an RTC bois-guilbert Athena
matsumoto [ __ ] for a date a demo Doh
Pocoyo male and as I acabas ocean io
signa contact upon a better now open
your mouth is the idea of the kind of
shambling zombie arms outstretched we
wanted to keep that feeling but we
didn't want them to be thinking but at
the same time as a lot of fun to have
them just become really stupid we have
to kind of elementally infuse zombies
they the ones that spit bile or the ones
that are kind of infused with fire or
electricity
no not a pity zombie tight ninja get
over there he only 45 EST also looks not
zombie Kyoto como no you escaped under
scalar master decade ago today on gaming
or story is my cell yeah oh cool don't
decay zombie re na na na kotoba night
kozy kar hum na do meet up tonight to go
do it use us all to look after beautiful
day don't mistaken antoje the kiddo we
talk all day no idea can t for you need
sorry DJ bikini nah don't be that split
a couple let alone a whole dos cosas was
most sauce nano zombie to move more than
food / you got the snare but hysteria
idea para tocar vital to market are
equal to the utter to cut in there so
cool so you gon G she knows or
bitterness own illness who can hear
every customer hey what it do so cool
has estemos another car till to this
name becoming could to a second or naka
de you need dat the universe there
motionless on hold so if you start at
ultimate zombie t to estimate the graph
da minha let you do it all iran a type
of a zombie attack took sega Thank You
mr. another whole operation
yeah Catherine school are totally a
funny a zombie ichiba jim was your
sister who may be useless but do you
gotta move on dear God mass media
tomorrow yeah / e tutto mami ki nobunaga
zombie know Miroku they are there solo
yo Massa you know okay our burrito they
may need us to his neck in a who nano
zombie co2 per oh so you was up till
they made us is only presentation mr.
you know we thought about how they would
act in horde and how they would act you
know when they're by themselves and kind
of came to the whole idea that we could
kind of differentiate each zombie by
giving them more of a unique personality
they kind of will get like memory
flashbacks of what their previous life
used to be our base minions on these
they sometimes they'll be walking down
the street and they'll have a cigarette
and they know they used to smell but
they didn't know they don't know how to
do it so it kind of plays into the
comedy aspect of it and our sergeant
zombies which are kind of more of our
mini boss on these they their
personality comes out a little bit more
so we try to we try to develop a whole
background for them and where they came
from
you